alright so thank you for coming I hope
you had a great lunch I really like the
key lime little things they were
wonderful so I'm Laurie hack I'm the
executive director of orchid and what I
wanted to talk to you about today is
persistent identifiers we've talked a
lot in this set in the in the meeting
today over the past couple days about
managing data but also in the huge
amount of time and effort that's spent
in that management of data how do we tag
the data after the fact how do we create
connectors to allow us to understand
that this item in this data set is the
same as this item the other data center
is somehow related that is a huge
expensive proposition in many cases it's
not done and it means that we end up
with large amounts of data that are
essentially unusable or inaccessible
because we don't know what they are and
and the value to to the various
processes were involved in so I was
talking with Anita yesterday and she's
like my dad always taught me to be
having a informative but also kind of
fun presentation so I thought I'd put
this up so alert this presentation is
all about plumbing and I think this is
one of the hardest thing about the the
position that i have with orchid is that
really orchid is a piece of plumbing in
our data infrastructure and most people
really don't want to talk about plumbing
they want to talk about more fun stuff
they want to talk about analysis they
want to talk about that really cool talk
this afternoon this morning about
ancestry.com is really needs but heat
really talk about plumbing there's a lot
of plumbing that goes on behind the
scenes and all of these different data
infrastructures it enables us to do the
analysis and so orchid is a piece of the
plumbing but as they say here it's not
sexy but I think we can all agree that
flushing toilets and running water are
something that we want to have that we
need to have in a civilized society so
bear with me through this talk about
plumbing so what are persistent
identifiers so their numeric or
alphanumeric persistent designations
that are machine readable okay this is
what I'm talking about when I need
persistent identifiers the are also
resolvable this is really really
important we're not just talking about a
number
we're talking about a resolvable
persistent identifiers so that if you
click somehow on this identifier you
will resolve back to a source document
or source entity now the entity can be
anything from an organization to a
person to an artifact okay meaning a
work a paper a data set etc okay person
place and thing so why do we care about
this what do they do exactly machine
sorry I start persistent identifiers
enable machine readability right in
today's digital age things have to be
machine readable they enable
disambiguation and they enforce
uniqueness how do we know this is the
same as this well if they have the same
ID we do and they also enable linking
and data integration and the great term
interoperability persistent identifiers
are absolutely critical for
interoperability so persistent
identifiers provide a simple basis for
digital data governance and what we need
for interoperability so remember that
digital data governance plumbing so one
use case something that's near and dear
to my heart publishing research findings
people think about publishing oh I have
a research finding I'm going to write it
up in a paper I'm going to submit it to
a journal and then it's going to be
published in people read it simple right
well there's all kinds of things you
want to know in that process that can be
enabled if you include persistent
identifiers in the process Sonia's
talked about some of them the research
resource initiative we've had other
people talk about digital labs online
labs how do we understand what antibody
was used if you want to reproduce an
experiment you actually have to know
what the antibody was that was use right
if it was the experiment antibody how do
you know about the protocol wouldn't be
nice to have some kind of identify that
can point you back to the actual
protocol grant ID who funded it which
organization funded which grant funded
it we're talking about open access how
do we know who should have access to an
article how do we know if the article
should be
access as mandated by thunder if we
don't know that this thing that you
publish was actually supported by
funding agency X grant why right and
then is there a dataset associated with
it who wrote it who's the author who are
the set of authors author names are
particularly difficult their name
strengths they're not machine readable
all of these things go into the
manuscript submission process all of
these things I wrote up here all have
existing standard identifiers in the
community that can be adopted now now we
go then to manuscript submission there's
a review process how do we identify our
reviewers how do we encourage reviewers
wouldn't it be great if there is some
way to acknowledge reviewers well maybe
reviewer should have an ID to maybe the
review itself should have an ID we have
the manuscript acceptance we want to
know who the co-authors are right now in
the publishing realm right now many many
times the co-authors are not uniquely
identified they're not actually asked
specifically for permission to be a
co-author so they're put on a paper and
some find out much later wait a second
why am I on tape right no idea was on
this paper wouldn't it be great if we
had some way in here to validate and
verify who the co-authors are and then
we have the manuscripts published well
it doesn't just sit there it goes out in
an index by any number of different
systems well in many cases in journals
the manuscript received something called
a digital object identifier the handle
that allows you to really resolve back
to the source document so that's
published with the manuscript and that's
submitted to something called crossref
right and so you can navigate back to
the source document but imagine if
crossref also stored these other
identifiers or other source the source
document would be associated with
metadata for these source identifiers it
can really make a difference in the
kinds of information you can get about a
document about the process but who
funded it all of these other things you
want to know if these kinds of
information is collected in a
machine-readable format it's already in
the document it's just done right now in
a way that doesn't support digital
understanding all right so this is what
we're talking about let's move on so I'm
going to go into raw raw and get you
guys all excited so the instant you
leave here you're going to go back and
either do it yourself or tell your IT
people to make sure your systems have
identifier Xin them okay that's my goal
today so there's similar issues of
tracking who gets credit and also trust
that exists throughout the research
ecosystem so today I'm really focusing
on research and development primarily
academic but commercial is included in
this space how do we bring identifiers
into this concept of making our work
making our contributions public so we
have issues of tracking and trust with
data sets with annotation with metrics
and evaluation with review processes
collaboration all of these things would
benefit from having persistent
identifiers so I'm back to plumbing
plumbing plumbing plumbing so we
hopefully agreed it's desirable I would
say it's necessary and I don't know
about you but I love going to home depot
and just kind of staring at the big
walls of things and how I could make
this and I could do that and all these
other things so we like to do it it's
something desirable something we might
like to engage in but I realize that it
requires design it requires change it
requires cooperation means you have to
get on the phone and talk to people and
it requires work to implement these
standards somebody earlier today during
these talk to us well where do we go to
engaging these standard processes
there's already 26 standards I don't
want a 27th one how do we know what to
do okay so it takes time it takes
thoughtfulness it takes some amount of
ruthlessness and whose patience for all
of this right you've got other things
you need to be doing why so I do it
because it's a problem that needs to be
addressed we cannot continue to move on
the way we're going now without
instituting some method of bringing
order into the chaos in our information
systems so the particular problem that
we address that orchid has to do is name
ambiguity for people so I'll talk about
that for a little bit and then I'll move
a little bit more broadly about why we
care about why we as a community should
care about persistent identifiers so
this is one slide that I almost always
show when people talk about well why
should we care about identifiers for
people so and this really focuses on
again the research community I'm going
to read a couple of these so on the top
actually I think I can use it on the top
here there's a whole thing of the more
than six million authors in a major
journal citations and abstracts database
more than two-thirds of them two thirds
of six million share a last name and a
single initial with another author in
that database two thirds so are they the
same person are they not the same person
I don't know it's hard to tell so an
ambiguous name in the same database
refers to an average of eight people so
anyone trying to understand linkages
information flows who is funding what
any evaluation scheme you get nowhere
because of this kind of ambiguity in the
name database you also have Declan
Declan over here is trying to find an
old friend from three years ago 30 years
ago named Dave Jackson right he can't
find this guy there's no way you can't
just do a google search and try to find
these people because there's about I
don't know a million different returns
you get for Dave Jackson wouldn't it be
great if when you did that search that
behind the name was an identifier and at
least you got tabbed entries so you knew
that this one was this Dave Jackson and
this one was that Dave Jackson and you
could find yours instead of having to
sift through them all we've also got
Julie Banfield who got married all of
the publication's she put out before she
got married have a different name on
them it's really really hard for her to
bring all of her stuff together how do
you do that when everything is based on
a name string where do you go to
register your new name
we've got yen's August Meredith Sorenson
who's in Denmark this poor guy has over
50 different iterations of his name out
there in public on different versions of
publications grants etc because he's got
four names special characters it's a
mess so anyone searching for him has to
know all 50 different versions of his
name to find his stuff and who wants to
take the time to do that you've got
Julia van der hoop the folks in the
Netherlands have a lot of fun with their
banders which one's the last name is it
the van is that the day or the hoop what
is it I don't know and so it really
really complicated to find her stuff and
then you have sweet Gupta when he looks
up pubmed for his name he's over 10,000
search results come back who has the
time to figure out what's his and he
can't fix it right it's incredibly
frustrating for the authors for the
researchers and it's incredibly
frustrating for the people who want to
use the data to inform decisions so
there is a need for us to engage with
standards so what's orchid iso orchid is
a nonprofit organization we were founded
a little over three years ago now we
provide a non-proprietary registry where
individuals anyone in the audience here
can come to orchid org slash register it
works on your little handheld and
register for your own unique identifier
okay your requires very little time to
register it's a public ID we do not
associate the ID with personal
information the closest we get to
personal is your email address you
control privacy and what information is
a linked and what information is
displayed so it is your ID you travel
with it wherever you go we do not link
it to financial information we don't
want that this is really a way to say
this is me this is my identifier and
these are the things I do in public that
are related to research okay I'll tell
you a bit more about how it works so
from my ID centric version of the world
the person ideas in the middle and
there's all kinds of other I
DS that work in links too ok so our goal
is to serve as a registry but also a hub
that links this person identifier again
to the things that you do in public so
how do you link to your funding well
through links between your orchid
identifier and your grant ID your orchid
identifier in the ID for your funding
organization how do you link to your
your your publications through a link
between your orchid ID and the DUI or
the handle on your publication ok how do
you link to your professional
association mall by linking your orchid
ID with your member Association
identifier ok or your abstract ID that
you presented at that meeting all kinds
of ways of linking so we're the
identifier registry itself and then
these ap is that enable these linkages
between you and resolvable other
identifiers we do not store publications
we don't want the content we provide
that kind of linking pointer service to
enable you guys whoever wants to consume
the data to go to the source document
and do the mining if you want all right
we also linked to other person
identifier so this is again to address
that question of what about the other 26
standards out there there is probably
not going to be any one answer to any of
these blue circles on here there's
different needs in different communities
but what we can do when we develop these
standards is to be thoughtful about how
to provide services that will enable
standards to point to each other so
there are other existing person identify
as one is called Disney once called
researcher IDs provided by thomson
reuters once called scopus author ID
provided by elsevier and there are also
internal identifiers for example your
nih commons ID you may have a faculty ID
or an employer ID any number of other
identifiers can be linked to an orchid
identifier some of those links are made
public on the orchid page and some of
them are resident inside your system so
what we're seeing universities do not
talk about this in a minute is actually
taking the orchid ID and
posting it into their faculty or staff
or human resources registries at the
University behind their firewall so they
can then use that identifier is a way of
linking multiple systems across the
university their library access other
kind of research access all kinds of
other systems at the University enabled
links between those using that one
identifier alright so where are we this
is my little ad we have been out for
about two years now with our registry
we're getting close to a million we
should hit a million in about a month of
people that have come and registered for
an orchid identifier what I want to
point out here again is raw raw
community the large darker blue section
on the bottom those are the individuals
who have registered for an identifier
because they've encountered encountered
the request to register through another
organization so for example a publisher
asking an author to register for an ID
when they submit a paper okay the idea
they're being the identifier becomes a
part of that paper and is published as
part of the metadata when that paper is
published okay funder is asking for
applicants to include their orchid
identifiers and they submit a grant
again that identifier becomes a bit of
the metadata on the awarded grant this
is what we're talking about it's not
about an individual saying I did this
it's an individual including that
identifier in a workflow in a process in
a system so it becomes embedded in the
document and there's provenance
associated with it and review associated
with it so that from a data consumers
perspective you can trust and verify
this information all right so in
addition to person names we've talked
about orchid in addition to person names
there are obviously ambiguity issues
with all kinds of other names names for
documents artifacts and also names of
organizations orchid interacts with both
of these but we don't we don't do them
okay so just to be clear this is a nice
piece from Wellcome Trust they did a
study on open access you have a lot of
funders that are man
that publications that come out of our
supported by federal funding or have to
be made available to the public outside
of a publisher firewall and what they
found was this is a great idea but if
you don't have a way of tracking who the
author is who the funder is what the
grant was you can't enforce open access
so there's been a real work here to
figure out not just who the author is
but how can we enforce standards for
naming as well so my main message if you
remember nothing else from this remember
orchid register become a member but also
we can't do this alone everyone has to
be involved in this process we have to
take a community approach to embedding
next slide is what somebody asked a
question about who there's a number of
different organizations here that we're
involved with there's cassirer there's
data site there's your cursors force 11
it depends on which community you're
part of which one of these different
organizations you will engage with or
should best engage with to work on
specific standards problems that you
have or just to learn about which
standards you should be using ok the
to-do list I see it has six minutes left
so three things three things integrate
these data fields when you're designing
your systems make sure you have data
fields to store persistent identifiers
for people places and things my main
pushes people let's get started with
people make sure you have a data field
it should be a day to feel that stores
the identifiers and the type little
pieces okay you need to collect these
identifiers during your workflows you
need to embed that collection into
workflow processes when you're
collecting person identifies please
please please never allow people to type
these things in bad idea you have to use
authentication you have to use logins we
actually provide public API is to
support this we'd like to use the number
one but you can do it using
authentication do it the right way don't
let people type the stuff in because
Indians with typos and we're back where
we started make sure people are
authenticating these identifiers and the
third one is
incorporate them into the things you
publish whether that's a data set or an
API call anything make sure that you
provide access to that metadata that you
have okay very quickly I want to take
you through who's using orchid and how
they're using it so you get a sense of
kind of variety of stakeholders involved
in this and the depth of ways that
they're thinking about integrating
orchid identifiers so we've got
publishers research funders professional
associations universities and other
research organizations as well as
repositories and other vendors so it's
going to go through these very quickly
publishing so we have publishers that
are not only taking the orchid ID when
you submit a manuscript they're also
publishing it in the manuscript so I
think this is the right one here we go
right here you can see that orchid idea
is actually now underneath the author
line okay they're also starting
displaying it in large index sites so
this is scopus there now showing the
orchid ID and you can search their index
using orchid identifiers not just name
strings anymore you can now do machine
readable searches okay there's also all
kinds of stuff that we publish on how
publishers can integrate with us and
let's see here also this is not just in
science it's also in Modern Languages so
social sciences and humanities are using
this as well so it's across the spectrum
of fields different publishers using
this we also have this idea well there's
a lot of people who spent a lot of time
reviewing and reviewing is an important
fundamental component of how we validate
research information so there's also a
huge push now to figure out how do we
acknowledge peer-review activities and
orchid is part of this as well who's the
reviewer how can we acknowledge them in
a validated provenance way so publishers
as well as platforms like faculty of a
thousand in science open are starting to
integrate orchid identifiers in to
review processes this is pretty exciting
we also have single sign-on here getting
into peer review signing on with your
orchid ID using what's associated with
your orchid identifier as ways of
qualifying of yours funding a number of
funders are using orchid identifiers we
have two that are requiring the use of
work
identifiers drain grant application
processes and more that are coming and
this is not just in the US i should
point out this is around the world okay
we've got sweden ireland does not
mentioned on here the us both nih and
deal we are using orchid identifiers fda
is as well and we've also got adoption
in Asia and Pacific Rim countries
professional associations have many many
different databases that don't talk to
each other very well they publish they
have membership they have meetings how
do we know if some of you publishes with
them is also a member is also somebody
who presents at a meeting or maybe has
an award they're looking at orchid as a
key across these different data sets
that enable them to allow this
information to flow they are starting to
this is geophysical union implementing
orchids and member records their
editorial databases and their papers so
this is all parts of the research
community really working to embed these
identifiers for people it's again not
just about people it's about
organizations it's about the content as
well but people are very very
fundamental to making all of these
things flow all right universities I
don't know how many of you have ever
gone through promotion and tenure I have
talked to many people that's been here
this nice guy and I like stealing stuff
from Twitter our number two of entering
and updating my publications indicate
that they were published in refereed why
should you have to do this right there
already published there's already a deal
why they've already been three of you
why should you have to re-enter this
data I assume you've spent three days on
a promotion and tender kiss getting all
of his data together to present why why
should it take that much time you should
be spending your time doing your
research and scholarship and teaching
not spending three days putting the
other pnt case so what work you can do
is this person says in an alternate
universe another you just typed in his
orchid linked it all up and went for a
run we can use these persistent
identifiers to enable information to
flow between systems and prevent people
from wasting their time doing
duplicative data entry and also frankly
improve the quality of information right
somebody was arguing why should I have
to worry about what format to put my
foot note saying well you shouldn't you
should just really have to have your
deal I there
and then whatever parser is on that page
can decide how it wants to present the
information you should have to do that
all you should have to know is the DUI
for the content all you should have to
know is the orkut for the person and
then let the information flow between
systems that's what we're trying to do
here repositories all kinds of place
store data a lot of part we're talking
about here is repositories and they're
working on building and support for how
do you submit data and curate data
involving explicit collection of
information on who is contributing that
data set and their contributor role and
so it work it has been integrated into
processes across a number of different
repository structures all right that's
my last slide of 21 seconds I'm so
thrilled so for more information on
orchid orchid work it's very simple it's
a free website we have technical
documentation our code is all open
source you're welcome to check it out
contributes we have a support if you
want to contact us just contact us at
support at orchid org and there's the
registration thing so many uses painless
to get one thank you